Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Clustered at
the Rawkode Academy.
Today, we have teams from Carta and Fairwinds
who have broken some Kubernetes clusters for us,
and they will attempt to fix each other's
clusters live on today's session.
Before we kick that off, there's just a
little bit of housekeeping.
First, thank you to Teleport, the sponsor of
ClusterT. And
if you've not seen Cluster before, then,
well, you're wrong. You should.
Teleport is a tool that we've used since
the very first episode. It allows us to
have access in a pairing fashion through a
web browser or through the command line client
and actually type in the same terminal together
and pair on problems, an invaluable tool when
debugging Kubernetes, and we're gonna see our teams
using us today. So thank you to Teleport
for that. Also, you should really subscribe to
the Rawkode Academy. And there's a button right
below this video that will allow you to
get updates to all new episodes of
Prasut, and I do my best to try
and provide tutorials,
guides, and walkthroughs for all of the projects
and the cloud native
cloud native landscape. I can't talk today. So
please subscribe, follow along. And if you wanna
come and chat, there is a Discord server
as well available at Rawkode.chat.
Now I'm gonna stop talking before I make
any more mistakes and jump over to introduce
our wonderful first team.
Hello,
team Carter. How are you both today?
Hello. What's up, everybody?
How's everyone doing?
Better
now that the pressure's off me and now
on firmly on both of your shoulders.
So can you just do us a favor
and just say hello? Tell us who you
are and share whatever you wish to share,
please.
And start with you, Mario.
Sure. Awesome. Thanks. My name is Mario Loria.
You may have seen me tweeting
Meminetti's
randomness and funny things, not incredibly serious.
I am a CNCF ambassador, currently a senior
SRE at CartaX along with this guy next
to me. We're going to be showing you
about great our skill set is in fixing
things.
I also do cloud native consulting from time
to time, so I've seen a lot of
different various scenarios.
Really
invested in helping the CNCF with cloud native
TV,
KubeCon conference, which was just announced the schedule
as well, and really love the overarching community.
My specialties are kind of in the networking
realm,
and the nuances of of doing things in
auto scaling and just building resilient,
cloud infrastructure,
of course, on Kubernetes.
And I love all the the little projects
that come about and things like Cilium really
really get me excited
about the feature of of
containers and and orchestration.
So really happy to be here, and thank
you so much, David, for setting this up.
Awesome. Thank you, Mario.
And, Mudi.
Hey, everyone. My name is Mahmud. I also
go by Mudi. I'm based in New York
City. I've been a senior SRE at Carta
for a few months. But before that, my
background was more
working with financial companies to setting up platforms,
Kubernetes platforms,
as well as AI companies to do large
scale
data processing.
So I've I've been on mostly doing
mostly doing software engineering, but more recently, been
doing more SRE type of infrastructure
type of work. So it's been exciting. I'm
also very excited about the upcoming KubeCon. Hopefully,
we'll see a bunch of you guys
in the audience there.
And, yeah, super excited about today.
Awesome. And you've been on before and absolutely
smashed it. Right? So this is gonna be
a cakewalk.
Oh, I don't know. This
Teams Teams is a little intimidating because it
sounds like
we have we're we're we're working against four
four very talented
folks from Fairwinds, so we're very excited to
see what they have for us. Yeah.
Alright. Awesome.
Well, that's the nicest piece out of way.
We're gonna get into the fun of debugging
Kubernetes.
So I'm going to pull up my screen
share here,
and I'm going to attempt to use the
Teleport CLI application for today,
which allows me to list the nodes in
the Fairwind cluster.
I am going to connect to the control
plane like so. You both should be able
to join through your own session. And if
you could just give me an echo hello,
an echo Moody, echo Mario, whatever you'd like,
let me know that you're in the session,
and we'll kick things off for today.
Thank you, Moody.
So, Rawkode, I'd love to go off the
beaten path, and I would love it if
you made another session just for me
and shared it on the screen. We have
dual sessions,
and people can watch and see what we're
both doing at the same time distinctly. Now
I think maybe Moody I'll let Moody drive,
and maybe I'll do some research looking around,
and he can make some of the actual
changes.
But I'm gonna join this session right now.
Thank you so much. This is a great
idea. I just wanna make it more exciting
for the fans. Well, this is a a
clustered first. We have never had a split
screen action on the go. So nice idea,
and let's see what happens. Blades and trails.
And I see that the Carta team have
left you a nice little hello message as
well. Isn't that sweet?
Oh,
yeah. They're saying, hello there, Carta. We're excited
you're here. We left you fun treats and
three fun treats, and don't forget the hints.
Cool. Thank you.
So so, Mario, shall we just see if
we have access to this cluster?
Should I drive,
or would you Go ahead. Take it away.
Yeah. Yeah. So we'll see qcl get nodes,
I think.
Oh, okay.
So we've got Mario taking a look at
the hints, and we've got Moody checking the
nodes above. So at least you have a
working control plan. Right? Of course. Good old
fair ones with that RBAC lookup. That's their
own homegrown tool. Of course, they'd they played
it into the the process. I'd love it.
Well, I was gonna say
wait. Wait. I don't think we should read
the hints yet. Right?
Oh, you oh, okay. I was just gonna
ask. Okay. Alright. Yeah. Yeah. Can you can
do whatever you want. Right? It's it's it's
it's up to you. I I think I
think we should read the hints when we
get stuck. I think it's a little early
to read those. Alright. Alright. Okay.
If fair winds are selling you bad, don't
open the hint yet.
So Oh, man. Alright. I am gonna start
your four to five minute timer. Thank you,
Noel, for the reminder. You may almost have
infinite time there. We now have a little
timer in the corner. Take it away. Good
luck. So so I didn't see the hints,
so we'll see how this goes. But the
what I'm seeing is get nodes is returning
what looks like pods. So these are not
these don't look like nodes to me. So
that's the first very suspicious thing that's going
on.
Can I get pods?
Can I get anything other than
pods?
Namespaces.
It looks even like it's a saved
it's a saved output. Like, the seconds are
not changing.
So
it's probably like an an alias or something
or a
function. I'm gonna say which kubectl,
see what that
so, yeah, let's let's go there and use
our bin
and let's l s
kubectl.
We have the Fairwinds team in the chat
written you on, I'm sure. Let's see. Let's
see if I
oh.
Nope. It is a binary. Gonna say, just
to see what kind of
file this is,
statically, like, execute.
This is great. K nine s on my
screen is just showing up just really well
on the stream, isn't it? I'm sure everybody's
loving loving this scrolling.
That's wonderful.
So I do have access, Woody, to the
cluster. So it's it's definitely a QCTL,
specific
thing, it sounds like, or something static.
Yeah.
So yeah. So I don't know why KubeCTL
is acting this way.
You're assuming it's KubeCTL.
Right.
So,
Mario, what do you think we should do
here? Or should we just use canines since
that client seems to be working? I I
kinda wanna just use canines. I'm worried about
oh, it actually displays pretty well for you,
yours. Okay. Yeah. Let's just use canines.
Like, I think most of, like, the added
actions and research is gonna be in there
for the most part, I think. So
Okay. Yeah. Sounds good to me.
So
oh, I think the terminal is getting messed
up now. It was working, and now it's,
like, a little. Yeah. Uh-oh. Just give it
a little How about how about now? A
little drag.
A little drag. Okay. How about now? Yeah.
Nope.
Let me just start over. Yeah.
Nines.
Oh, man.
Having trouble getting it to fit on the
screen.
Yeah. That's because I resized my window. Sorry.
I'll drag it back. Oh, there we go.
Oh, there we go. Thanks.
Nice. So okay. So let's first find out
if the application's running, I guess. So
should we try to look at the services?
Oops.
Service.
And
so it's on
Port 30000.
Is is is there an ingress that we
can test with, David?
Or
Yeah. I know he can click the
entry and Yes. So if I pop over
to the web interface, we do have the
clustered application exposed securely via Teleport. I can
click the button, and we will wait.
Oh,
yeah. I'm testing it. It doesn't look like
it's gonna
it's not doing anything, it looks like. So
interesting.
Okay. So
let's see.
Let's find out why. It did load and
we got failed to connect to the database.
So for anyone who's not familiar,
the application cluster is a small Rust application
that speaks to a Postgres database
inside the same namespace to display a quote.
It cannot touch that database for now.
Gotcha. So so yeah. So let's take a
look at maybe the if there's any logs
No logs. Okay.
Maybe I'll describe the deployment and just take
a look at what's going on in the
image. So it looks like it's using the
right
image name here, so that's good.
I wonder if it's like a
like, it's like a network policy thing potentially.
Or
So I do see a network policy actually,
and it looks like it's got a
pod selector
for it is allowing, though. It's allowing egress
traffic to
the
Postgres
database.
However, I have a feeling, Moody, maybe we
just delete it, and you can view that
if you do in k nine. It's just
a colon network policy.
I have a feeling we should just we
should nuke that one, though.
The default one. Right?
Mhmm. Yep. Yeah. Yeah. It looks like it's
seems like it's denying
denying
egress,
it looks like.
Oh, you see a deny rule?
Or is that an oh, it's an allow
rule. I see allowing egress traffic. Yeah. But
I think for safe measure, maybe just removing
it would be
Okay. If it's not in the way.
Let me delete it. And now let's test
the application again.
Oh, there we go. So the application loads
now.
Yep. Excellent.
And you get the watch face video, which
means we have version one of the clustered
application.
Awesome.
So
let's see. Shall we try to upgrade it?
What do you think?
Yeah. I'd say let's just go for it,
and then we'll see what hapload breaks from
there.
And I'm actually reading the comments right now
too because this is fun,
and it's a nice dopamine hit. And,
Kelly wrote, so you don't wanna fix kubectl.
And, my answer to that is I do,
but, like, our main priority is upgrading from
version one to version two. And so I
kinda just wanna get that done.
I definitely do wanna figure out what they
did because I'm interested
in how they broke that and got some
static output, but it's a binary. It's kind
of it's kind of interesting to me. So
maybe we'll come back to that one.
But the big thing great question, Khalid, is,
like, I just wanna solve the the main
thing that we're trying to do first, and
we have API access. So,
k nines is, yeah, letting us do that.
So
So so here's,
what I just found out is that I
I can't update the image tag for whatever
reason. It keeps sticking back to v one
even though I changed it to v two.
So
there we go. Let me try it again
just to make sure I did it right.
Oops.
Yeah.
B two.
And if I describe it again,
yeah, it still says v one. So
admission controllers,
you think?
Yeah. I think that's probably the the logical
logical one.
Now I'm interested.
Yeah. Yeah. Indeed. There's a there's an admission
controller right here. It's saying Okay.
Well,
I I can't really see it because it's
the window's so small, but trying to
yeah. Create
the operations are create pods
down here
for a mutate. Yeah. So shall we just
delete it?
I think that's probably a safe bet.
Yeah. Let's do it. The sledgehammer approach. Let
me look at the deployment again
and
change to v two again.
Okay.
I don't think it worked this time either.
Uh-oh.
Interesting. So maybe that was like
a that was like a red herring. I'm
gonna look at the replica sets.
Oh, so there's a bunch of replica sets
here.
It looks like the one that's running right
now
was it's forty hours ago.
Right.
Interesting.
I wonder what happens with yeah.
Oh, go ahead. I was just gonna say,
I wonder if we just if we actually
clear those all out and just let the
deployment object
recreate them naturally,
so we we kill anything that's currently running
and just let just to get any
semblance of a modified replica set.
Just delete everything. Delete them. Delete the cluster.
Just delete all all all of these. Right?
No. Yeah. All I would say all of
those. But, again, just kind of a a
blanket strategy. Nothing too focused.
Yeah. Let's see what happens.
Do we okay. So we get a new
one.
We got a new pod.
If I describe this one,
we do it. Did it. Still v one.
Okay. Let's
look at the deployment again.
Edit.
It's a nice effect that changing the image,
there's no new state in admission controller and
it's still v one. I like that.
It's not doing anything. So it's not detecting
any changes to the deployment.
I'm thinking we should look at, like,
maybe the controller manager.
What do you think, Mario?
I
just look took a quick look, and I
didn't see anything.
But,
yeah, let's let's look through it once more.
Maybe you'll see something that I did not.
Yeah.
So
go to the manifests. Oops. Kubernetes manifests.
K.
I'm gonna I'm gonna do a v I
cube controller manager.
Swap file.
Oh, are we both editing the same file
or something?
It wasn't editing, but I'm out of it
now. So go ahead.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there we go. So,
yeah, I wonder if there's anything
in here that's
suspicious.
The image
what image are we using? So We may
as well upgrade to one twenty two while
we're at it. Right?
I don't know about that.
Wait. The control plane is running 121 now
or is it 1122121,
it should be running.
122 came out yesterday or today. So I
was just making a joke about upgrading at
the same time. Yo. YOLO. YOLO upgrade live.
Yeah.
So,
yeah, I'm not seeing anything that interesting.
We could look at maybe some of these
files.
Leader Electrue
port zero?
Port zero was What is update? Actually
that's actually normal. Yeah. That's normal. And then
yeah.
Nothing Something that's weird to me is the
something that's really weird to me, and I
don't know, maybe, David, you can verify this,
is,
if you go back in that file, Moody,
you'll see that there is a
go to the options, if you will. You'll
see that there's a
scroll down. There's a request header client CA
file,
and I don't remember seeing that on our
cluster, but that might be something that's normal.
I could be wrong, though. It's just kind
It is normal. That's okay. It is normal.
Okay. Okay.
Mhmm. Cool.
Yeah. So okay. So let's
think again. So what else is watching the
deployment? So there's the
so we checked the the webhooks. Should we
look at validating webhooks maybe? I didn't really
check that.
Yeah. That's that's true. I although I I
think we would get an error
Yeah. That would It wouldn't be something
wrong.
They're laughing at you in the chat. I'm
just just letting you know. That's all. I'm
just a messenger. That's fine. Just a messenger.
Yeah. Yeah.
There there is one right here. So
I'm trying to see what it does, but
should we
just delete that one as well?
Okay. Yeah. Oh, wait a second. I'm interested.
Does it have what was its config?
So,
yeah, I'm here.
So it says
Just to see a bundle.
Service is cube system admission.
It would mostly fail.
Apps v one create resources.
Deployments
are in there. Yeah. Side effects, none, and
I'm not seeing anything about notifications.
So I'm just very interested in how it's
not, like, notifying us. The failure policy was
fail.
So you should and, clearly, get a message
if you try and update the deployment.
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So Fairwinds is giving us a a
break here and telling us k nine doesn't
show the validating admission webhook messages.
We're gonna have to file an issue on
that because k nine is supposed to do
everything.
So
You could always fix cube control and, you
know, look at it that way. I I
really wanna fix cube cube control. Yeah. I'm
I'm looking forward to that. But let's first
check this out. I'm gonna delete this guy,
and then
let's let's edit the deployment.
I
will be so impressed if it doesn't update
the image, though.
Yeah. If there's even another
break here, that would be interesting.
Still? That's awesome. Well done, fair one. Fair
one. Mhmm.
Really? I have an idea, but I'm I'm
holding it. I'm keeping it.
Very interesting. Okay. Let's see. Yeah. It's still
v one. I'm gonna look at replica sets.
Just gonna kill this. Well, actually, no. Let
me look at deployment and just make sure
that it was edited or it was not
edited. Yeah. Set is right. People are enjoying
breaking cube control these days.
This is not the first time that's happened.
Yeah.
So Ivan telling you, you should you should
have cube control by now. And for everybody
wants to see you get cube control working.
That's that's all saying. Should we just do
that? Let's do that. Yeah.
So
I don't know where to start. So let's
look at maybe, like, is there anything weird
in the batch RC file?
Take a look here.
Wait.
What was that? Oh, there we go. Look
at that. It's right here.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh. A function because it doesn't take over
a which thing.
I've used that break before in clustered.
Interesting.
Thanks a lot, guys.
We're just copying all stuff other people have
done. No originality
factor.
Come on.
KubeCL?
Oh, wait.
What? You'll need to resource your bash shell
or or maybe even just bash again until
you yeah. Bash.
KubeCTL.
Okay. It's back. It's back. We have kubectl,
guys.
Nice.
So now yeah. So now what I was
trying to do was edit. Yeah. Do an
edit from there. Yep.
And let's see what that tells us. Yeah.
Clustered.
So you're expecting the k nines was actually
tricking you here or leading you astray.
Potentially. Right?
It was. Look
at that. Okay. So
mustard could not be patched. Mission webhook
denied.
Sorry, Carta. Love fair waste.
No. I can't get that. Okay. Oh, there's
an eighth burn from George there. It's not
original, but you fell for it, Mario.
Yeah. That's true. That's true.
So so let's look at the API server
actually.
So I'm thinking maybe there's some admission webhooks
plugins enabled.
So maybe if we look at
manifest cube API server.
Oh, no. Someone else is editing
the file. I'm in it right now as
well, but I don't see anything
that would lead me to I don't see
any other admission plugins, though.
Node restriction only. Yeah.
Wait a second.
I'm trying to figure out how they're
I mean, they're running some webhook somewhere
for sure.
I mean, the fact that they had a
custom response saying
love fair winds.
I mean,
there must be a web server somewhere. So
I'm gonna just look at just all the
pods that are running.
Just get a overview
here of what we have.
Okay. I'm gonna do some research.
Oh, there's okay.
API server.
Interesting.
I love it when people say interesting because
it means I have no idea what's going
I have no clue what's going on. Services.
So I can share I
can share a thread I think is worth
investigating if you want, or I can give
you some other you can have some more
time to kinda
How are we on on time, I guess?
You've twenty six minutes left.
Okay. How about in in, like, if in
five minutes we don't know, we we we
Alright.
Go for it.
Oh,
Mario, are you are you seeing Yeah. So
the webhook? Had we looked at the validating
webhook configurations yet
or no? I don't I thought we deleted
it. Maybe they did. I thought so too,
but it's it's back.
Yeah.
Great.
Kubectl dot
yeah. Yeah. Go ahead and do it from
just kubectl.
And so we had deleted the validating webhook
and the admission webhook.
Right?
The the the mutating and the validating, and
they're both back, it looks like. Okay. Right.
Something is something insists on having those around.
So let's try to delete them from here,
actually. Yeah. So I'm gonna say
delete mutating webhook
defaults.
Oh,
sorry. Is it called one?
Oh, there. Yeah. So it says deleted. Now
if I get it again,
done,
Does it come back in a few minutes?
It does. There it is. Back almost instantly.
Yeah. A nice comment there from Fairwinds. Kubernetes
is the self healing system.
And another comment from Ivan, customer
custom
admission controller response is all part of the
Fairwinds customer service. There you go.
So
Rachel from the Fairwinds team has said if
you need hints, let them know.
What about We we also have those hint
files for sure.
Should we look at Cron?
Maybe?
Maybe. I don't
I don't really
Something is recreating those admission controllers. Right?
Yeah.
I'm trying to think what it could be
because I didn't see any pods that were,
like, suspicious
in the cluster. I mean, we could search
around and kinda Yeah. We could definitely look
around. I was thinking maybe doing a
let's see.
Like, image.
I'm gonna say
tripod
everywhere
and grip
image.
Oh, it's image and with a capital I,
I think.
Let's just do that.
Okay. So here are all the images that
are running.
Can we see anything weird?
I see something weird.
Oh, there is a wait. I see a
Cilium op wait. Hold on. That's on my
screen. And
your right
here.
Right?
VIP.
What's that, Luis?
Do you see this this image right here?
The the cluster Data. Dev cluster
dev, Sudar Sudar Manjur.
Interesting. I don't know how to read that
name. Sorry.
Yeah. You find that part. That seems suspicious.
Okay. So
let's maybe do a,
I don't know, before five or something.
And
well, actually, we can just say
dev.
Cilium. A
Cilium
pod is running
a clustered image. What's the name of that?
Hold on.
Hold on. Why? Oh, it's Okay.
What namespace
is that in?
I'm gonna go further back. What's what's the
name of that one?
C four
50, whatever.
I'm not seeing that.
Oh, it's it's on the okay. So the
pod name is CiliumJVKNR.
There we go. I was looking at the
container. Yep. Okay. I'm gonna mute that.
Yeah. So I'll switch to your screen to
see what you're you see. So
JV So this is the Did you tier
one. Did you kill it already? I killed
it already.
And it's back.
It's back. Same image.
What's managing it? What's under the metadata? Good.
That's a good
well, it can't be
is the VIP something that's there?
Is what I use for ingress. Okay. Yep.
Got it. Okay. That's what I was figuring.
Yep. So this is the the the main
data inside is fine.
So something is managing
that
That image. This is what it appears to
be because I have a feeling.
No. That is the actual
operator. Okay.
I'm gonna try to describe the
well, is so the pod got a new
name when you deleted it?
Is that what happened?
A new pod spawn, which means I'm guessing
there's can't do that. I'm guessing there's a
controller behind it.
Yeah.
So if you
describe it, right, you should be able to
see what's managing it and what created it.
Long night terminal is weird here.
So It was this one.
I'm assuming API tier control plane.
Firms worker two.
Alright. So so, yeah, are you describing it,
or should I?
I'm looking, yeah, I'm looking at the describe
output right now.
It's gonna be assigned, pulled image.
I'm gonna try with the Okay. O y
o y m o as well.
Alright.
Interesting.
Cool plane.
Do you see I'm trying to see if
there's anything.
So, David, you said somewhere
in the metadata, we should see something,
maybe? So I wanted to know where it
was getting his name from. But if you
look under the spec, it's using the generate
name.
Yeah.
So it's making it look like a pod
even though it's not a pod.
Yeah.
And I'm trying to see if if there's
any
thing
that says how
it was scheduled or who scheduled it.
I
wonder okay. So I wonder if we can
see anything in the
events
eventually.
No. This is sixteen minutes ago, so nothing
oh, perhaps in the namespace cube system. Right?
Because events are namespace.
So
here we go.
Oh, did you stop a container
three minutes ago?
I guess that's the one.
The the seven f is the new one.
Yeah.
So there's no owner ref. So
yeah. It it's hard to trace this.
Yeah.
So yeah. It doesn't look like it's a
cron thing. It doesn't look
You have eighteen minutes.
We check for cron jobs in the cluster.
Sure. I I wonder if that's that's what's
going on.
Get cron job.
Nope.
Any job in the cluster?
Oh, man. I think it can only be
one of two things. Right?
Either
there's a road process on the Linux host
or
Yeah. The API server image is not the
API server image.
Which I thought we checked. Did we? Let
me Well, you checked them. Manifest has the
correct image name, but not that the image
on the host is necessarily the correct image.
Oh,
okay. So
could we use, like, what, container d?
Yeah. Yeah. You can use cry control
images, I think.
Okay.
You'll need
a real run type endpoint. I can take
that for you.
Oh, thanks.
Yep.
Var
run container
d container d.
So
kubepi server
control manager.
I mean, we could potentially inspect it.
I mean, you could repill it and see
if the image ID changes. And if it
doesn't, there's well, I mean, I don't wanna
see too much.
Here if you wanna ask questions or there's
hints as well. Yeah. Thank you. So I'm
just gonna copy the
run time flag. There there's a favorite trick
on cluster that's been done multiple times with
images,
which I can talk about if you want.
But I'll I'll give you some give you
some better time.
Thank you.
Maybe is there a
is there an inspect?
Yeah. Inspect images.
We're gonna try that.
So if I say inspect image and then
copy the
kubectl server
and it was version one twenty one dot
two?
Okay. So let's see what we got.
A nice comment from Noel as well. Container
d is not distributed,
but I don't think that applies in this
case, Noel, because the API server is running
on this machine. There's yeah. There's only one
control plane node. Right? So Yep.
I mean, this is
this looks like the right
instructions
as far as I can tell. Doesn't look
like a random Docker file.
Kubernetes authors.
I mean
yeah. This I mean, it looks like the
right image as far as I can tell.
Mhmm. Should we look at controller manager,
maybe? I mean,
I I actually think we're
I don't feel like that's what's going on,
it could be.
Mario, what do you think?
Yeah. I kind of agree. I don't really
feel like that's what's going on, but
we also could be wrong. So
Yeah. Go ahead and take a commander.
Unless it's like Not really seeing any problems,
like, weirdness with the
API
pieces. So
or I'm sorry. The cube system pods for
the most part. So
Yeah. They all look pretty normal. Right?
Right.
So let's step back and see what what
was the ish the last issue we faced.
So we were
we're trying to delete the webhooks,
and somehow they still
come back.
Something's creating them,
and
we think
we we tried seeing if it was the
images,
and
the images look good, at least the API
server image.
We could probably check the others, like controller
manager.
But
yeah.
I guess we could look at the host
processes and see if there's, like, a something
in the background that's running.
Let me try that. Let's just Let me
fix that for you.
Oh.
So
Oh,
okay. Thank you.
Well, Fairwinds in the chat have suggested that
logs are often useful.
And Rachel from the Fairmans team says trust
your intuition.
Which one of them? Which intuition?
There there were so many of them, but
let's take a look at the yeah. I'm
looking if there was any processes that have
been
kind of running in the background doing Alright.
Thirteen minutes.
So
oh, the other thing we I just remembered
there's a pod that every time we kill
comes back as well. Right? The Cilium
dev one.
So
should we look at the logs of that
pod
eventually?
Shoot.
It's one of the Cilium
more recent Cilium ones.
This one. Yeah.
Oh, yeah. I see here
validating webhook.
This is definitely receiving the requests, it seems,
for the
for the validation webhooks.
So Yeah. So it's probably the the
yeah. It's probably what's creating
those back.
Is there a what's it called?
Can we edit it so it can't get
scheduled possibly?
Oh,
not sure.
What what am I trying to run here?
I'm trying to see there was a
API resource
for
Mhmm.
Was it called API resources? What was it
called?
Oh, you're wait a second. Your command is
not found,
which is weird. Oh, thank you. Did you
set up an alias? Yeah.
T l
API resources.
Yeah. You can I I get I get
it out of my session? I'll let Moody
drive.
Thank you. So so, yeah, I'm taking a
look here. So I'm trying to see if
there is any
API services. That's what they are. So get
API services.
I keep using the alias. Oops.
So
auto scaling. Is there any weird
API services here? No.
Looks normal.
Yeah. I can't figure out what
what schedules that pod.
Is there Damon's?
Did you check the process table? Did you
go through it looking for rogue non Kubernetes
processes
or even rogue non Kubernetes containers?
So
do you mean like this?
Like
yeah. Like, literally just running
that and going through it and seeing if
there's anything that doesn't look like a standard
Linux process.
Which is always the needle in a haystack.
But,
I mean, something something that's running on this
machine.
Yeah.
I try Bash.
I mean, this looks like our sessions,
and then
if we go up a bit
Oh, you want me to scroll? Sorry.
Or Oh, I I'm do you see me
the do you see me scrolling? Or No.
I I we won't see you scrolling, unfortunately.
You can just let us know what you
find.
Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead and, yeah, scroll up.
You you do have hints, remember. We can
always
read those things. You know what? Let's maybe
we should use that now.
The Venus suggesting the BPF
BP filter is a road process. No. I've
thought that before in previous episodes. It's always
there, so now I ignore it. I think
we're okay there.
Yeah. Let's let's check out those hints, I
think.
Yeah. So
what are we checking? Sorry. I got I
got lost. I think they're in the root
directory,
but you can check out whichever ones you
want.
Alright. Let's start from the top.
Hint one.
Having fun with functions yet? Yeah. We've already
figured that one out, I think. So
as slow as our
the RBAC
lookup will help you find RBAC permissions that
are difficult to discover.
I think we're past that one, or it's
probably it doesn't seem relevant right now,
which you agree.
I
I'm not sure what what it actually solved.
What was the issue for the RBAC lookup
one?
I don't really know. I'm wondering if it's
something with the webhook or something like that,
but I I would rather solve the issue
in front of us.
Wait a second. Okay. So this is a
command. I I just realized something.
Static pods.
Could it be a static pod?
Yeah. That's kinda what I'm thinking,
but I I'm not sure where, like, it's
defined at all.
And I think
It's it's in here. So It was I
I looked. I didn't see it in there
at all.
But There's no there's no static pod at
all.
And the manifest directory?
I mean, you could store multiple definitions in
a single file. I I and I didn't
I didn't see any in there, and I
looked through them as well. They all looked
valid.
Well, you know what to search for? Like,
custard.
So
Oh, right. True. Yeah. I didn't I
didn't grab. Yeah. You could definitely grab.
Yep.
ETC
Kubernetes
manifests.
Term first, I think. Right? Yeah. It might
be term first. Yeah.
I'm gonna just say dot dev.
Yeah. Nothing.
So
what about Cilium?
Nope.
Yes. It's not not a static pod.
Alright. At least we rolled something out.
So back to what we were trying.
You've got more hints?
Yeah.
Let's look at hint
three. Did we look at that one? Oh,
yeah. I think you've identified as the Rogue
pod, but you're not sure how it gets
there.
Right. Yeah. The best practice prevent attackers from
injecting malicious content and doing extra damage.
Go to this URL.
Okay.
I've I don't really know if this has
anything to do with what we're facing.
I don't know that I could be wrong.
It's it's definitely a it's it's definitely I
think this is this is it. Yeah. We
this is the last hint. So Fairwind's team
is saying that the call is coming from
inside the house.
And you have six minutes.
Fun.
The call is coming from inside the house.
Let's try. Sorry. I'm gonna
Yes. Should work. Right?
P s?
Oh, no. I just can't spell runtime endpoint
correctly.
Oh, p s is fine.
So yeah. So
So there's no
Two days ago, twenty six hours ago as
the Cilium agent.
So that's
suspicious.
I mean, what we checked that and that
was I mean, you could look at the
logs maybe too, but I'm pretty sure we
looked at that and that was an issue.
You could actually do a describe. I think
create CTL as a describe or something. I
know Docker did
Info.
I don't know. But
I wonder
yeah. I wonder
let's try that. You said this like, a
describe on
from The container ID.
Is there a describe command?
I don't know. You'd have to scroll up
on the help output maybe.
There's
attach create There's inspect and inspect p. Yep.
Yep. I was just gonna say inspect is
your go to probably.
P and then the You could add in
the pod ID.
Is this it? Oh, no.
Plot ID. The the other one on the
end.
Mhmm. There we go.
So
what do we look for now?
So the this one, we suspect, the one
that has the the the the bad image.
Right? The colon dev
image? Correct.
So let's find it.
Wow. We probably should have crept.
Yep. No. It's not in there.
Mhmm. Okay. I
actually grepped in the bottom, but you guys
can't see. But Oh, did you? Okay. Okay.
Got it.
The pod recreates itself.
So what about container d's configuration,
actually?
Maybe?
Should we try that?
Or is it My initial guess was that
they were using a container d feature to
pull in their own image instead of the
official one, and their API server was rogue.
But I'm not entirely convinced it feels like
that anymore. I don't think that's what's happening
at all.
Yeah.
Do you guys think it could be, like,
the container deconfiguration itself?
I mean, you can run container deconfig dump,
and it will allow you to take a
look and see.
So
same command. No. Container d, actual the daemon
process, the config space dump.
Failed to load TOML file.
No such file.
That normally works. Is there any
other
oh,
the directory is not there. Yeah. I mean,
you let me maybe I just forgot the
command, but I thought it was config.
Yeah.
So we just don't have
we don't have one.
It normally prints up a. I don't know
if that's
something
new, different, or not. But
yeah. If you don't have a config, then
it's unlikely they're using that
cheat to pull in the alternative image.
And you've got one minute and forty five
seconds.
This is a tough one. I gotta say,
really tough one.
Cilium operator.
Yeah.
He do Cilium namespace dash o wide.
Oh, can you repeat? Sorry.
Get pods in the Cilium namespace with a
dash o wide on it.
Yep.
Oh, it's in cube system. Right?
Right?
Oh, yeah. It's What?
So
So I was I was it's not like
it's a rogue Cilium process. Something is modifying
the Cilium pod only on the control plane
node with that image.
Like, you run a if you just get
all that output YAML and filter for custard,
we only see one. Right?
Yeah. Let's see.
Describe
pod
in cube system. Wait a second.
You you find something?
I don't know what we did, but I
was messing around on canines,
and
I was able to change the version to
two, and it's sticking.
Oh.
So
I don't know if we did something where
we disabled it. So all I did is
kill the pod that had come back again,
and nothing else came back. And then I
edited the deployment,
and
it looks like it has successfully stuck to
v two.
And you can go view that.
Is that the proper version, Rawkode?
Normally, it takes a couple of refreshes and
stuff before it finally Gotcha. Fills it.
Right
now, it looks like v one.
No. It still says v one. Yeah. I'm
not sure.
Yeah. I could be something else as well,
but
you do a describe on that
pod,
Moody.
Describe pod? Sure.
Yeah. Which pod? Yeah.
Which pod? Or just describe on the the
deployment, whatever you wanna do. Yeah. Clustered
pod.
Extra PO.
Oh, sorry? We've got an extra PO. You
can just delete that.
Oh. It's still v one.
Yeah.
Alright. We are out of time.
Yes.
Oh, man. That that was tough. That was
tough. Seen
Street was The hint did not did not
tell us much. I I I couldn't
couldn't tell from the hints what's going on,
but thank you, Fairwinds team. That was fun,
though. Yeah. Well, the Fairwinds team, I'm sure
they'll they'll tell us in just a moment
what happened, and there'll be a pull request
to
the depository with the breaker notes. And Rachel
from the team is saying you were so,
so close. So I'm gonna have to say
goodbye to you both, and we'll find out
what it was soon, and we're gonna tackle
cluster number two.
So thanks again. It was an absolute pleasure,
and I'll speak to you both soon.
Thanks. Awesome. Good luck, guys. Bye. Yep.
Alright. I will pop over here and encourage
the Fairwinds team to come and join us.
And I'll also take a moment just to
say thank you to Teleport for sponsoring Clustard.
If you want to support the show, you
can go check out Rawkode.live/teleport
and check out there is an awesome product.
You've seen it in action. I encourage you
all to check it out.
Alright. Let's pop over.
And we have our first member of the
team.
Hey, Rawkode. How are you?
You're I'm good. How are you? Oh, there
we go.
Alright. Your team is now filtering in.
Hello, Rachel.
Hello. How are you? You guys are a
mean team, I gotta say.
Carter, you guys are amazing. Y'all did such
a good job, and y'all were so, so,
so close. So thank you for being good
sports because, honestly, that was that was amazing.
How how just how close were they?
It's hard to tell. I didn't see
how the pod actually got deleted. So
I think they were close. But
They they have one more item to do.
And yet
hint number four four.
That was the last one for us to
fix. Ah,
unlucky. Alright. Well,
I'm pulling up our cluster
now. Oh, sorry. Luke is here too.
Hello, everyone.
Alright. Let's
start with a little bit of an introduction.
We'll just start with Rawkode and and kinda
look around to Luke, Andy, and Rachel. But
if you could just tell us your name,
who you are, and maybe something you like.
Well, I'm Rawkode.
I'm
just a, you know, engineer
manager. Just joined recently
to Fairwinds, and really excited to be here.
Rachel?
Hey, everyone. Rachel Sweeney. I've been at Fairwinds
about a month. Absolutely loving it. Worked with
customers, helped them with all their problems that
come up.
Yeah. Super excited to see what Card has
done for us and dive into this cluster.
Andy?
I'm Andy.
I've been with Firewinds for about three and
a half years, working Kubernetes for five, and
something I like is Kubernetes,
quite honestly. I know that sounds silly, but
I really enjoy it. So go ahead, Luke.
Hey, y'all. Luke. I've been here for a
couple years.
Mostly working on internal tooling and open source
stuff and
still doing some SRE stuff as well.
Excited to try out this cluster.
Awesome.
Perfect.
Alright. People are asking in the chat. How
was that pod getting there that was doing
the naughty thing?
I posted the code in the chat. There's
a link to the repo that I just
opened up for everybody, but it's just a
static pod or not a static pod. Sorry.
A naked pod,
but it catches a sig kill and recreates
itself
and catches the signals and then creates a
new version of itself every time you try
to delete it.
So you scheduled the first one manually, and
then it would schedule itself autonomously
after that. That is so sneaky. I like
that.
And then the one last
Sorry.
Go ahead. The last piece is that we
took the v one image that needed to
be updated and we tagged it as v
two and took the image pull policy and
set it to only if present or not
if present.
Nice. Alright. Very sneaky.
Okay. Let's pop over to our screen share.
Hopefully, you all have access to this.
I am going to run TSH LS and
I'm gonna SSH
onto the Carter control plane one. You should
all be able to connect to this session.
If you can give me an echo hello
or something to let me know that you
are there, and we will get started with
this.
And a lot of love and oh my
gods for that SIG kill capture reschedule thing.
That was super sneaky.
Alright. We've got
all of you there, I think.
So I would suggest you export your cube
config, check for our control plane, best of
luck,
and let's let's go for it.
Cool. Andy, are you driving? And I will
start your timer. Oh,
yeah. The
teleport
command lines is not like them, so I
am gonna join from here too.
One.
Alright.
Did leave us some hints. I'm gonna leave
those for now.
Let's
just
see what we've got here. Alright.
Can't access resource nodes.
So let's take a look
at our
oh, so it looks like they've
moved the original admin config.
Let's just take a look at the one
that's in the dot here.
I think I'll just list the one we
have.
Let's see. Let's try the
end the.admin.com.
Have the control panel? Access.
Hey, John. Well done. See, he's all there.
I don't know what's wrong with this one.
And
looks well, the user was changed from Kubernetes
admin to cluster admin. Nice.
Alright.
So
Are we trying to update it?
That's what I was gonna do. First, I
was gonna look for any
rogue pods, but that's probably just me thinking
along the lines of what we did.
There is nothing in the default namespace.
Is the app just isn't there? Is that
Seven hints. What have they done to this
cluster? I don't know. Can
we check and see if the app has
even loaded?
We can. Me pop it open.
Do have a deployment?
The deployment exists in the cluster.
Oh, but there's no pods. Got it. Okay.
Yep.
Alright. Let's do describe here.
That's interesting. It says one ready, one available,
one up to date.
That's a true none.
Yeah. That's interesting.
Yeah. That's that's a nice effect as well.
Can we check Rback?
Can we check Rback on the
user that we're authenticated as?
Yeah. See if we can view pods.
So the pod's running, but we can't see
it.
Yeah. I don't make the SDF available on
my Kubernetes clusters normally.
Oh, I thought I had it in my
batch. Wanna see. I but it must not
happen. Oh, I forgot to install it. That's
right.
I have it sourced,
but not
looks like we had a
cluster.
We were the Kubernetes admin users. So
So what are you looking at right now?
I was like looks just looking at our
back.
So your hypothesis is that kubectl get pods
isn't working because of permissions. Right?
I think so, but that doesn't make a
ton of sense because I'm not getting the
I mean, you could run getting any pods.
A different error. Off, can I? Right? That
that would show it. Yeah.
And I did dash a, and I can
see pods in other namespaces,
just not the one for the replica set.
That's what made me think it might be
scoped.
So it would be maybe a role binding,
not a cluster role binding for the namespace.
What would make
the API think the pod exists?
The pod doesn't exist from the perspective of
get pods, but not the perspective of the
deployment.
So we can see the deployment, you said?
Yeah?
Yeah.
Do we care if we can see the
pods? Can we just try and edit the
deployment?
Oh, we get a internal server error from
the app, potentially.
I didn't actually see We did get an
internal server error.
So it is not running.
It's definitely not running. That's correct.
Yeah.
Does it look like postcast maybe? Or it
could be on a worker node. As I
said, do y'all see the the the container
itself running on the worker nodes?
Take a look. There's a taint on the
worker nodes for
cluster t app.
There's what?
There's a for the cluster tab. No schedule
on the worker notes.
Okay. That's just so it doesn't get scheduled
on the master.
No. It's on the worker notes.
So it can't be scheduled on the worker
notes.
Oh,
but then
why would the deployment say it's ready?
Yeah. So there's one ready, but we can't
see Really
freaking me out.
Got it. Okay.
So let's see if I can
remove those tanks first.
I don't I need to resize my window
or something here. Hold on.
Yeah. Yeah. Let's see what's in the scroll
disappears, if you just kinda resize a millimeter,
it kicks it back into shape normally.
Got it.
Okay.
It definitely looks like I was doing some
weird stuff there.
Still no pods, though.
Yeah. And there is a selector
in the
deployment.
And that selector or just because that selector
is normal.
It's matching the pod to the
it's already v two.
It's doing your job for you. What's going
on? I I yeah. Could we do the
other jobs?
How nice of your character?
Did y'all find the the container running on
the other on the worker nodes by chance?
Nothing's obvious. I do control Nothing's running.
Nothing's staying running on
nothing's on worker two except for Cilium.
Unless it's hidden, it's something like Cilium.
The database is also not running.
Same deal. It says it's got one ready
pod.
Let's go look we should maybe look at
logs.
Yeah.
APIs
are on the logs.
Some of our own advice from the last
one.
Alright.
Somebody's gonna have to have me with control.
Is it just there we go.
Wait. There was no on our cluster, there
was actually a pod for the logs
or for the API server. Sorry.
Now the container's running,
but there's not
there's not a pod for it.
I'm not missing it.
Oh, you're not.
Alright.
Because node name Carter work Carter worker one
does not exist.
Is it specifying the node in the deployment
maybe?
Does have a node selector for app clustered.
That's not a node selected. That's the deployment
selected for the pod, isn't it?
People are always so mean to these clusters.
Very interesting. They really are.
Come on. Is it time to dive into
a hint? I'm pretty sure.
Yeah. That get pods not showing anything is
interesting.
Yeah. So there is a node selector into
the deployment,
Andy.
Yes? Okay.
The hint one was the first thing we
found.
The brokenadmin.com.
Right?
Yeah. Seems Oh, there it is.
There it is.
We just removed that.
Yeah.
Yeah. We don't need that.
Uncurrent, undesired,
zero running, zero waiting, zero succeeded.
What is
Alright. Let's
let's go for two. There's seven of them.
Right?
You got that one.
Yeah.
Alright.
Love the hours, by the way. Good job,
Carter.
Find the birthplace of the unborn pods. Do
pods have parents, and are the parents still
alive?
Interesting.
Pods.
You have parents?
Control.
Right. The scheduler's not there either.
Oh, no. It's it's right there. Oh, it's
back. Yeah. There's there's a scheduler.
Maybe we should check the config.
Moody in the chat says it's payback time.
That's fair. Fair. That's fair. Fair?
That's fair.
System cube scheduler cannot list resource config maps
in the API group
in the namespace cube system.
So maybe check logs of.
And we've got a bunch of failures to
watch,
failures to list,
so we should check the permissions on queue
on the scheduler.
What do you think? What what were you
saying, Luke? Sorry.
That we should look at the log of
Kubelet.
I'm looking at them now on one of
the work on worker two,
and it's
there's some errors. So I might need to
look at the configuration
if we wanna open up.
Failed creating a mirror pod?
What about
about the
RBAC
in the Kubelet config?
I think mirror pods are related to static
pods.
That is correct.
I've never known why it calls them matter
of pods, but they're static
pods everywhere.
No. I don't know if that's it.
I do need our backup lookup.
We've
relied too much on our own tools.
Feel free to show off. I don't think
I've seen our back lookup before.
Show me the coolness. Get it. I'm gonna
get it.
So they
You really don't see any cluster.
Carter's cluster does not seem to have Fairwinds
Insights installed. No longer is it.
Oh, boy. Sorry. Could not resist.
Shameless.
Know
is software we create for best practices,
cost analysis, stuff like that. So
I'm not seeing anything in static manifest that
look unusual.
So what does the r back lookup do?
So r back lookup is giving me I
just searched for cube scheduler or just for
scheduler. It's giving me the service account, cube
system, cube scheduler, has the role cube scheduler,
and the role binding
system
leader locking KubeScheduler.
So it's basically just finding all mentions of
scheduler across RBAC and then linking them together
so I can see all the permit like,
roughly the permissions that or where the permissions
for the scheduler come from.
So
has the role system leader locking
system cubes
scheduler for cluster role.
So maybe we marked with
cluster roll system.
Yes. Get get. Get get get. Classic.
This looks
vaguely correct.
What was the
alright.
So that's the wrong path.
We go to a worker node and look
at the logs of
kubect there.
I mean, they're able to join the cluster,
but I see some errors and some other
things.
This is
yeah, there's a queue API server error.
So I probably don't see that pod.
I've opened a session on worker one. Anyone
wants to drive on it. I can switch
between them.
Oh, great.
So it looks like the QLET was stopped
a couple days ago. And then when it
started up, it just started spewing these.
So
Yeah.
Let's look at the service itself, maybe,
the definition.
Let's
see.
In
a while.
Looks like the API server and the controller
manager were modified.
At least they have different time stamps than
some of the other pieces.
Okay.
There we go. Queue config.
So what lead are we chasing right now?
Is this the the scheduler complaining it can't
read config maps, or are we looking into
something else now?
I'm looking into the QLET configuration right now
to See if it's been
messed
with
Don't see any pod security policies.
Static path is as expected.
I do find it interesting that we don't
have the API server
in the pod list
Yeah.
That it's running.
Yes. It does not like me right now.
There we go.
Definitely a bit stuck. Anybody got any issues
here?
Something still tells me it's.
But
yeah.
Do you call that? So it's failing to
create
it's failing to create the
API server pod here over and over and
over again. So that's
quite likely our issue. Although, if I did
pause that the API server is responding to
me at all,
what were you saying, Luke?
It says I'm available to validate pod request
there.
So maybe there's something
wrong with
manifest.
Something else here that we missed, maybe.
Nope. That's just
responding to me over and over and over
again.
We just got a meeting in ten minutes.
Alright.
There's
no webhook configurations that I can see.
Just in case,
replace the API server with something.
I'm
not sure I would catch
the ML error live like this if there
was one.
Right.
So most of that, it's okay except for
one line.
For one line. Where
did your cursor start? I remember that from
watching the
digital. It was exactly where the cursor started.
Where did your cursor start? Oh, yeah. Admission
controller lane.
There's an extra one.
Enable admission plugins, no restriction,
pod security policy.
Anybody familiar with admission plugin, sir? Because I
don't remember what the default is now. The
default is node registration.
Registration?
Interesting.
There were no pod security policies that I
saw, but
no restriction over that registration.
Yeah. It should be known registration instead of
restriction. I think there was one more change.
Other registration?
Yeah.
Next one with you.
It's not rough.
The chat. Very
quiet for a change, which is unlike some
I think everybody is is pretty stumped.
Yeah. Good job, Carter.
You got twenty minutes left.
Time flies when you're on the sun.
When you're live on YouTube. Yeah. Bye. So
Cube API server
is
not ready when you do Cryo CTL pods
list.
We'll see
if we can get logs on that one.
So there's a second pod. Oh, there's already
one that started a few seconds ago. Can
we just kill the other one?
19 hours ago as well.
Four?
I I would change the node registration back
to restriction. I think that was a slip
of the tongue,
but it should be restriction.
That's the default value.
Okay. Got it.
Failed to start and and that's probably our
old message here.
Let's just Yeah. See what we got.
Okay. We have an API server. It's pending.
If you look at the cube controller manager
under controllers, there's a lot of minuses. Minus
replica set, minus deployment, minus staple sets.
You disable the video control things.
Uh-huh. And looking at if you do CryCTL
pod list, that one was modified nineteen hours
ago, seventy two days ago.
You're right on it, Andy. Up at the
top, one of the flags. Yeah. No replica
set controller, no deployment controller, no step for
set controller, push traps, talking cleaner. They went
to town on that. Yeah. A few lines
on that. I think we just I'll retrofit
it. Remove that.
Just remove that line. Right? Yeah. Just leave
the asterisk. Or do you yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Because asterisk should be everything.
That's right. Sneaky.
Sneaky. Sneaky.
So we have still one oh, yeah. Controller
manager. An API server. There you go. Yeah.
How are you getting responses from an API
server
anyway? Weird.
I don't know. It I think it was
just rejecting the pod registration,
but the controller the the
containers
I have no idea, actually.
We have the containers ready now for clustering.
Woo hoo. Hey. Hey.
Starting off.
You get that? A couple. Okay.
Two replicas set.
It'd be lying if I said I thought
we were out of the woods.
Yeah.
It's probably more.
Alright. Let's see.
That started.
It says it's running.
Postgres. Happy? Is
pending.
Can we try updating the deployment, or should
we try the front end first?
Oh, we can.
I feel like it's gonna say it can't
reach the database.
Yep. I think we're about to get a
angry man time out.
Alright.
So
not getting any
reason
why
Postgres won't start.
Let's go to specified in the deployment because
I don't think I see it in there.
It's a staple set. Staple set. Okay. Great.
Let's see.
What?
So it's got a config map mounted to
it. That could be missing.
I would have expected to see a message
about that, though.
Generation two, so it has likely been modified.
Yeah. Can we look at generate the replica
set and just go back to the other
one?
There's no Rawkode set for safe old sets.
Oh, right. Right. Right. Right. I was thinking
of
I wonder if scheduling
or alternate strategy.
Have you described, like, the project?
Yeah. I did. There was no events.
But what causes pending?
Yeah. It can't scheduled.
Yeah. Normally scheduling, I think. Right?
Oh, yeah. Or scheduling.
So
so I had selector on that one too,
maybe.
I had a nice look.
Or, like, the update strategy. Maybe that's
Yeah. I hate myself for that. Like, the
service is Postgres, and the stable set is
PostgresQL.
That's on my to do list.
To the strategy.
Yeah.
Not sure. Just checking things.
I just see just, you know, some something
from scheduling or, like,
for the other strategy. Right? Otherwise,
Does it have anything on the pod called
mode name? It says that it has been
scheduled.
That's what the scheduler puts into the pod
once it's running? Yeah. So if you edit
the pod, I would expect to see the
value node name somewhere. I mean, you could
always add it manually to see if they
confirm it as scheduling.
And I'm just saying my advice is often
wrong and leads you down the wrong path
for twenty minutes. So, you know,
use it at your
discretion.
Just take the scheduling logs.
Next thing I would do is.
Found the watch.
That's been going on
since it started.
Although, I did just restart because we didn't
have it before. I don't know.
It's been quiet since then, it looks like.
We got twelve minutes.
Alright. It's time to open here at five,
I think.
It's the final resting place for power
nodes.
So
why can't this one be scheduled?
You got a very interesting comment in the
chat from Don O'Neil.
Not all default schedulers are default schedulers.
Default schedulers misnamed.
Oh, interesting.
Maybe I noticed he was paying attention.
Tables are
Schedule in the end.
Yeah. Once you see it, I'll set you
can't unsee that.
Oh, it's too blurry. Oh, so sneaky.
That is good.
One letter off.
Yeah. It's crazy.
Yeah.
My wife's actually standing outside my window with
a sign that says scheduler typo right now.
Hey. We got a we got a database.
Will it blend?
Oh, alright.
Well, looks like we still don't have an
application.
So I would start looking at the clustered
service.
Yeah.
What's the connectivity look like?
So Teleport expects cluster to be running as
a node port service on port 30,000,
I believe.
We're not getting anything anymore? Because before, we
were getting a database failure.
I think we've had internal server error every
time. Yeah. We expected a database error, and
we never got one. Never got it. Okay.
Oh, there it is.
We can also try curling local host on
30,000 just in case they broke teleport, but
I don't know if that's okay.
Just in case some noise changes.
What was that last thing you said? I'm
sorry. You could call local host from 30,000
to confirm if the node port service is
working.
Thirty. Yeah.
I'm gonna guess it's not.
Death by a thousand cuts here.
Did
you just
oh, you deleted it. Okay. Never mind.
Yeah.
I restarted it.
But it seems like we're
would
Teleport give us an internal server if it
just couldn't connect at all?
I believe so. Yeah.
K.
How much time do we have?
Eight and a half minutes.
There's a there are a few replica set
versions for
for clustering.
I checked the image pull policies always,
and
the image
is
correct.
So I don't think it's a rogue image.
I I don't I don't like that we
can't curl localhost on 30,000.
Yeah. That that seems networking
ish. Yeah. I'm
I don't know if you caught Mario's introduction,
but he did talk about his networking skills.
Yeah. I
We
talked about this.
Silly in network. Silly in network policy. We
talked about doing this, and we didn't do
it.
Yeah. We did.
Yes.
That was lucky.
And Steven Augustus.
That's awesome. You got the dance. Nicely done.
Seven minutes to spare.
Left out some furthest. Harder. We left with
Steven Augustus.
You would have kicked yourself. It was a
silly of network policy that blocked you from
there
from finishing it. So I'm glad you cut.
Nice work.
Alright.
Carter,
that was amazing. That was a lot of
fun. Yeah. So much fun, Beverly.
Well,
thank you all for joining me, and congratulations.
You got through that with a whole seven
plus minutes left to spare.
And
your seg signal capturing to respond our process
was definitely ingenious.
I'm not gonna forget that one in a
hurry. Thank you. And so thanks again It
was wonderful. For joining us. Hopefully, we'll get
you back another time, but
I'll say goodbye for now, and have a
great day.
To
to everyone else, thank you for joining us.
Thank you for watching Clustered. Thank you for
engaging us in the chat and supporting both
the teams here. Thank you to Carter, to
Mario, and to Moody. This was a fantastic
episode. Thank you to Teleport as well. Please
check that out at Rawkode.liveteleport.
We'll be back next week. Have a wonderful
day. I'll see you all soon. Thanks.